hello my name is Jose Marti Garcia and I
will be presenting new advances in the
geography framework things like new geo
protocols ways to transform your
positions and a new bridge to the
geometry functionality
so in this talk Chris and I are going to
be reporting on ongoing work to improve
a data set so data set is an object that
has placed a double role in the word
from language on the one hand it allows
us to visualize and interact with data
in the form of nested arrays and
associations on the other hand is an
object which we can query in and and get
information from that data so it's
natural to separate the two parts and I
will be talking a bit about
computational and structural part first
and and then Chris will be talking about
the typesetting part so with respect to
the structural part my main effort is
been to make data set faster more
predictable I will explain in a moment
what that means but essentially there
will be in this first round of changes
no relevant change in computational
behavior so my part is kind of boring in
comparison nothing changes so I will be
quick increase will then explain his
changes in in the typesetting part so
one of the main things in relation to
the structure and competition in data
set is the relevance of a type and I
will explain in a moment what that means
so I'm trying to scale down the
importance of this type to make it
faster also we want to have more
documentation on data set and that would
be the initial round of changes then
future bigger changes will include using
different internal representations
depending on the structure of the input
so sometimes when you have an array of
the data and expressing it as nested
associations will repeat the keys
multiple times so we want to avoid that
we want to also use different backends
like using data set to interact with
data in in files also databases
we want to have better interaction with
other factions in the systems like
time-series and also of course we want
to extend the query language in several
directions so yeah so what's the
relevance of data set type so for
example what we can able it
so we have our example here of data
scepter for four planets and yeah so
what I was saying before I know that
goodness this is gonna well okay like I
can explain the world so I was going to
get the type out of this object then get
the type of the transpose object and
show that depending on whether you yeah
so yes I was going to show that
depending on whether you get the type
directly after the transposition or do
you do this which is normalizing and
getting the type again although you get
different things and because the the
types of the data set effects various
parts like a typesetting - may end up
having the exact same data with
different type settings and this is
something that has been reported as a
problem and in fact yesterday I learned
that sunder has created a a function
repository function just to force the
computation of types on data set so this
is something we want to avoid and the
new idea that we will be using in the
future is we will have a faster way of
computing types competed only when
needed and being cast to avoid the
computation so I'm sorry but this
function will be less useful in day in
the future yes yes something else that
it's worth having in mind is that query
computations do not use the type so so
in that front we got that safe and then
final thing I want to say is that we
also want to remove we is this evaluate
one
see yeah this yeah so another thing that
dataset has always had is this metadata
so so the output form of data of dataset
has the data the type so I was going to
show some times before the Samata and
then some metadata so this ID has been
always problematic because you can you
cannot equate the same letter with
itself because it will have different
IDs so we are planning to remove this
object which is used only to keep track
of the history of the dataset so
something I wanted to know is whether
anybody is using this ID for any reason
if so please let me know because I and I
want to know why because it is going to
go away very soon okay so yep
no actually can mess it up in the sense
of of producing types that are history
dependent and then leading you into the
conclusion that you have a different
object while well you actually have the
same no no okay so that was my quick
recap of changes that are going to go
and into the structure of data set and
now I will let Chris continue okay Mike
okay all right so um I'm gonna tell you
about interactivity and formatting
changes to data set and there quite a
few more of those and I really want to
get your feedback on this too so as
you're listening to this think about
whether what we're proposing is going to
work for you if you want changes or if
there's something that's not on our list
that's on yours let me know at the end
of the talk so the first thing you'll
see is a very slight formatting change
the the scroll bar here is grouped with
the content with a frame what you don't
see immediately are some new in our
activity a new interactive controls so
if you right-click on a header there are
new sorts and hide controls so you can
sort and reverse sort by column and you
can hide columns you can hide rows to
give you a more focused view into your
data set was that we did so hide
collapses it to a small just a very
narrow column to save save screen space
yeah and so the comment was at the row
was kind of large the reason was I mean
just I'll do it here the row was taller
because it doesn't it doesn't currently
hide the entire row it hides item wise
which may or may not be a good thing the
advantage of that is you can go in here
and you can expose one of these because
they're there and accessible the
disadvantage is that it's not as compact
as it might be that's that's not a
settled detail yet okay so this is what
you get by default when you look at the
planets there's an item just displayed
option that gives you explicit control
over how many things are displayed so
this will display four rows and gives
you a scrollbar so you can access the
other elements that goes by levels so if
you say items displayed
I just displayed 4 - so that displays 4
rows and 2 columns and gives you a
horizontal scrollbar for the column you
can specify any number of levels so if I
go if I go here and say all all one one
that says display all planets all planet
properties one moon per planet and one
item per moon which is just the mass
there's a mass and radius it says hide
them hide the radius and like under the
planets there's an exposure thing here
that says you can click to see all the
planets there's also a vertical exposure
bar I wish you can click to see
everything under the the moon's column
okay there are a whole slew of new
formatting options and these essentially
parallel what you can do with grid
currently but it's generalized to the
multi-level structure of data set so
there's background item style item
display function alignment item size
hidden items and analogous options for
the headers so you control the
formatting of the header separately from
the content of the data set so let me
explain the option syntax is very
flexible and complete and I'll explain
it using the background option so if you
just give a single value mm then that
applies to the entire data set so this
makes all the items in the data set
have a light blue background you can as
you as you can with items displayed you
can you can specify multiple levels so
in this case I said make rows light blue
make columns light green well every item
exists in a row and a column so it mixes
those colors and you get the the
resulting mixture various options some
of them combine things some of them
override depending on the nature of the
option and I think we're doing the right
thing this is this is very useful if you
want to have like indexed columns and
indexed rows that so you can more easily
follow your data set it's nice to have
the colors combined this works like
right like this okay so as he's pointing
out as in grid you can give a speck
which gives you repeating colors or a
list of color so this says make the
first row light blue make the second row
light green if you enclose those in
another layer of parentheses and you get
cyclic colors which is a useful thing to
make it easier to follow the rows or
columns in your data set and in addition
you can give you can give explicit rules
the color individual items so you see
okay so this one just makes the earth
row light orange in addition to the two
the cyclic background
and in this case I'm saying make earth
throw light orange as well as the radius
column light orange and you see on the
left-hand side here it says all comma
radius that might be a little cryptic if
that is the path that it gives you if
you if I hover over radius you see down
here what you probably can't read it
it's annotated here all radius it tells
you the path to that column that's what
you give on the left-hand side of the
option
if giving colors oops that's the wrong
one
I'm using I'm using the side notes of
the presentation for the first time and
it's not working as smoothly as I
expected it would
okay so that's not it either okay so you
can also by giving by specifying earth
radius I can color an individual item
and the data set in addition to what
I've done before
now if that is not flexible enough for
you in place of any any place you can
put a color you can also put a function
that returns a color and the function is
fed the value of the data set item the
past of the data sytem as well as the
entire data set so in this case
it's being awfully slow
the documentation
the documentation
yeah it'll it'll be completely
documented
I'm having a hard time getting my inputs
into my notebook hang on just a second
okay there we go so in this case as I
said you can put a function in place of
any color you can use that to get more
insight into your data by coloring by
value in this case I've made every every
passenger whose age is less than thirty
I've highlighted that with a cyan
background question is is there will it
be an option to have a legend we haven't
considered that now yeah the question is
how would you I mean you probably don't
want to have that pure function in your
legend yeah that's that's something to
think about
I'll make a note of that okay so
I think it's useful for both I'll get to
that you can do that yeah okay
so just like with items you can you can
use a header background option and you
have control over the backgrounds of all
the headers this has make all the row
headers light orange all the column
headers light blue
okay just like background option there's
an item style option which controls the
formatting of the content so you can
make that you can make the age row bold
18.2 call it out yeah three minutes left
pardon new queries that's Jose is
Department not mine I'm just talking
about formatting yeah sorry this is
going slower than I anticipated because
of the using the presentation things
I'll try to speed up a little bit so
there's also an item display function
which gives you complete control over
how things are formatted so this is the
the Titanic data set as you get it raw
but you can change the way that those
data items are presented by giving an
item display function so in this case
instead of showing at numeric age I'm
using the age to govern the length of a
bar so I get a kind of bar graph
presentation of that data and going
further
going further I can map the the sex to a
symbol for sex and give a check mark for
who survived so you you can present a
dataset in pretty much any way you want
to by using that item display function
there's an alignment option which does
what you would expect there is an item
size option to control the cell size
vertically and horizontally there's a
hidden items option which gives you
programmatic control over what I showed
you earlier with the interactive
controls to hide things though that's
the that's the end of the current for
adding options one thing that's new in
it will be new is an 12.1 the data is
not stored in the notebook with the data
set which is bad that means if you
create it if you create a data set
output you restart the kernel it no
longer has access to the data
you can't scroll you can't drill down
you can't do any of the interactive
stuff you can only do the top level
presentation that is now fixed so by
default when you create a data set
output it stores the data in the
notebook that's governed by the summary
box data size limit which is currently a
megabyte so if the data is less than a
megabyte it'll store it in the notebook
if it's greater than that limit let's
set it down to a lower value
so I'm going to set it down to a
thousand a kilobyte and now now when I
evaluate this I get a button I get a tab
at the bottom that it says it says data
not a notebook store now it's just like
house MRSA right works so you can click
that button and the date is in the
notebook if you want okay let's set that
limit back to back to where it was one
more thing in twelve point one data set
I'll just I'll just tell you about this
now show you at twelve point one data
set does not function properly within
dynamic or within a manipulate
environment doesn't have any activity
scroll bars don't show up it works now
and within dynamic just like it does
outside pardon in in within dynamic or
manipulate that's what I meant to say it
doesn't work in twelve oh yeah yeah
sorry okay let me just quickly go over
other things which I can't show you but
they're on the agenda one is a
truncation function so you currently
don't have any control over when
datacite data set decides to shorten an
element and show it in a lighted form
will give you an option that gives you
explicit control over that as so it'll
control when something is lighted and
there'll be another option truncation
display function that you can explicitly
specify how things are lighted using
short or shallow or or your own function
there are cases where since the data set
considers any level of list or
Association to be part of the data set
rather than the date
if you have data which is say a 3x3
array data set we'll think that's part
of the data set and not anatomic item we
will provide an option to give the
explicit control over that as well
and
these are items which are on the agenda
they definitely won't be in 12.1 they're
still under discussion whether we're
going to implement these or not but
maybe something you want is on this list
if so you should let me know we don't
currently support internal control
scrolling the scroll bars are only for
the external top-level rows and columns
technically it's a hard thing to do so
we're inclined not to do it unless
somebody really wants that index headers
is adding headers too if you have an
array currently associations have keys
that would give you headers but if you
have an array it doesn't have any it
doesn't show when your headers for
indices row and column locking so if you
scroll a data set some some items will
stay fixed
multi-column sorting so you can sort by
one column and then a second column to
break ties orientation option you don't
currently have any control over what
decisions data set makes and choosing
columns and rows we may give you
explicit control over that there are
many cases where data set does strange
things like you drill down and suddenly
things in a different format we're going
to address that people have asked for
pivot tables tabbed data sets like in a
spreadsheet and grouping by frame style
there the idea is if you have a say a
three dimensional array you get one two
dimensional block and there's no
differentiation between the sort of the
top-level blocks and the plan is to use
line weights graphical line weights and
the frame styles to show you that
structure okay so that's all I have to
say we've gone way over sorry about that
are there any does anybody have an
urgent item on their agenda that I
haven't talked about
yeah the question is will be implemented
in cloud and desktop definitely yes
importing so so you have it can you give
me a scenario okay so you want to export
the data set import it into another yes
the the options will go with it is that
what you're asking if it'll lose the
options or not no those will go with it
their question is how do you export a
dataset as an image well what I would do
would be rasterized export rasterize of
data set yeah if you want an image you
have to explicitly rasterize it as as
vector graphics do you want to export it
as vector graphics well that's a good
question like an SVG or something I
haven't tried that I don't know what'll
happen yeah so the question is does the
do the custom display functions override
the automatic formatting like in dates
and so on currently you're given you're
given the raw object to operate on to do
your own formatting there will be some
sort of way of indicating that you want
to to use the automatic formatting so
you can have an if this says you know if
this do my formatting otherwise do the
automatic formatting
[Applause]